making news from Iraq Parliament has
accepted the resignation of Prime
Minister Idol Abdul Maddy as he formally
put in his papers on Saturday it's done
little though to calm protesters who are
demanding a total overhaul of the
political system well 400 people have
died in the violence since protests
began in early October Mohammad
yong-joon is live for us in Baghdad so
Muhammad the parliament has approved the
Prime Minister's resignation what
happens next well has as of now
Parliament has accepted the resignation
that means that audible melody is
officially resigned as the Prime
Minister and that his cabinet is also
resigned he is basically now going to be
head of a caretaker government with that
same cabinet for at least 30 days what
happens next is that now the Parliament
has asked the country's president about
ham solder to choose a successor the
next prime minister typically we're told
that that process should take 15 days
but that if it takes longer the maximum
amount of time for a new prime minister
to be named is 30 days of course this
isn't it off and parliamentary
procedures and governmental procedures
typically tend to take longer than the
deadlines that are outlined inside of
Parliament than in the Constitution this
is really uncharted territory right now
it's unclear exactly what's going to
happen I can tell you though that here
in the epicenter of the anti-government
demonstrations above that Tahrir Square
are we've been standing all day we've
spoken to the demonstrators they tell us
that this is a good first step they are
glad that the Prime Minister resigned
they are glad that the Parliament has
also accepted that resignation but they
are worried that somebody who might take
the position next may not be any better
and once again we must stress that these
demonstrators day after day they have
come out and they continue to say that
they do not just want to see the
replacement of a figurehead they want to
see a complete overhaul of the political
system here and then it up as it
Mohammad Abdu live for us in Baghdad
thanks Mohammed